OK, so that about does it for our introduction to Lightning inside Unreal Engine 5.
We covered a lot of topics in this, so thank you for sticking around for it.
We first took a look at some Lightning terminology as well as the light types that
are available in Unreal.
Then we had a bit of a deep dive into what Lumen is and how you can use it,
as well as how it works in conjunction with Nanite and virtual shadow maps.
We then took a look at the static Lightning solution that we have in Unreal Engine 5,
which is light maps, as well as all the other things that are connected to it,
including reflections, IES profiles, visualization modes.
And yeah, I really hope that you had a good time and that this was informative to you.
Hope to see you in the next one.